[музика]
чим чоловік попростіше діти і підвищення
здоров'я
сказав там багато людей не було то чим
харпаніший це більше начать Я прийшов
галстуки в костюмів
хто при галстуки то більшість шарами
значить доповідаю вам що тільки що
взагалі нас приблизно сидить 400 і голів
профкому це другий третій курс і перший
курс валют де ми з ними домовляємося як
ми будемо разом з ними дихати явку маємо
сьогодні можна перепрошу вимкнути бо
тому що все це працює це вже
шановні пані та панове продовжується
робота міжнародної серпневої щорічної
наукового педагогічної кооперативної
конференції освіта освітяни не зламані у
війні вона розпочинаємо роботу локації
наука та інновації ефективні дослідження
для безпечної освіти хочу перед початком
нашої роботи усім нагадати що наш захист
відбувається із дотриманням усіх
безпекових вимог у випадку виникнення
загрози Прошу всіх переміститися в
укриття також Нагадую що ведеться запис
роботи нашої локації для того щоб усі ті
хто з технічних причин не зміг
доєднатися до сьогоднішньої конференції
могли переглянути запис нашої
конференції
прошу також усі свої коментарі для
учасників які доєдналися онлайн залишати
разом і запитаннями у чаті
адміністратори будуть надавати відповіді
на ваші запитання а також наразі потреби
будуть перекоровувати їх доповідачам А
зараз Дозвольте запросити до вітального
слова ніколаєнка Станіслава Миколайовича
ректора національного університету
біоресурси і природокористування України
Академіка Національної академії
педагогічних наук доктора педагогічних
професора будь ласка дякую шановні друзі
прийміть на щирістю вітальні стіни
нашого університету з великим без
задоволенням Поглянув би на всіх вас
потиснув вам би руки і ми готові завжди
до діалогу я тільки що колегам сказав що
я прийшов прямо звідси від спілкування
старостами 2-3 курсу і другого курсу
магістрів в залі Зараз у нас перебувало
ми закінчуємо вже 400 десь студентів і
університети На комбінованому графіку з
до серпня має десь приблизно більше 5,5
тисяч студентів які навчаються дві зміни
по кількості бомбосховищ укриті і так
далі І так далі маємо явку по
факультетам від 70 до 90% частина
скажімо там економісти менеджмент і так
далі а всі інші інженери там прикладні
всі спеціальності природничі всі
навчаються в Жигулі Наш університет в
цьому році буде святкувати навчальному
році тобто в слідуючому календарному 125
років майже 90 тисяч випускників якщо
взяти тільки роки Незалежності Це
87.90 вже народних депутатів дискотека
10 членів уряду це навіть єсть фактичний
варіант Нобелівської премії Анатолій
швиденко який вчився в нас і докторську
захистив зі свого господарства час живий
працює у скажімо у Австрії
Шановні колеги наші університет не
стоїть осторонь всі ми до єдиного беремо
участь у підтримці збройних сил Ми
навіть посаду таку вели в нас був
мобілізаційний відділ А сейчас та ще
зв'язки збройними силами і от ви бачите
сюди скільки наших дітей сьогодні
співробітників беруть участь у захисті
нашої країни скажу відверто що на
сьогоднішній день не перерахували більше
11 млн уже коштів і цей процес
продовжується це без особистих вкладів
студентів викладачів На жаль маємо і
Прикинь прати прекрасних ребят ви бачите
вже втратили і Цей список мартірок такий
сумний від На жаль продовжується і Ми
дуже переживаємо царство в небесного по
центру Я дивлюся як зараз Сергій
Романчук він був капітаном нашої збірної
чи з ним футболка такий прекрасні ребята
прямо як кажуть серце вбивається
небесне що стосується університету дуже
коротко скажу маємо 13 факультетів і три
інститути
інститути факультети його насіння але
інститут закриває всю галузь наприклад
рятівництво факультет скажімо єсть Ну
наприклад там
механізації інженерної Да він не
закривав цю раму є маємо 9
науково-дослідних інститутів які
поєднують дослідження разом із освіти
також в нас іще є 11 відокремлених
структурних підрозділів у нас в
університеті 103 кафедри 400 000 400
лабораторій і таке інше ну мені цікаво
розказати один приїхав до мене ректор і
каже Я хочу відкрити дві спеціальності
яку лісову каже справу хочу відкрити
агрономію Я кажу не проти А які в тебе
сили є у нас каже кафедра називається
лісового господарство та агрономії
походив походив через дві години приходу
вашого каже лісового господарства це
цілий інститут також 15 Кафель агрономія
- це цілий факультет Також там говорю 20
Кафель і не 20 12 То вже він да пішов
так не знаю открив не відкрив
маємо півтори тисячі викладачів
254 доктора Вау представники трьох
академії у нас великої академії єсть
національної аграрної академії майже там
три десятки членів маємо і в академії
педагогічній кілька осіб і в цьому році
є сім юридичній академії в нас академіки
наших Шевченкове студентів маємо десь на
перше Ну на 1 вересня в тому році мали
приблизно 17 тисяч випустили зараз
стаціонару приблизно
12 тисяч чотири з лишніми заочників і
так далі відокремлених навчається ще
майже 10 тисяч людей як позиціюється в
університет ми вперше в цьому році
попали в міжнародний рейтинг КС от серед
на цих університетів це означає що ми
маємо певні зрушення позитивні до цього
ми позиціонувалися 5 років у Східній
Європі по рейтингу і східній Азії
сьогодні коли значить міжнародному
рейтингу ведемо роботу зараз міжнародну
велику зокрема відкриваємо дві філії в
університеті ціндао Іллі у Китаї по
цимдав по спеціальності від медицина вже
маємо дозвіл ліцензію А у Індії вчора
закінчили
[музика]
експериментально перевірку і так далі
дуже складний процес півтора року іде
маємо з десятком добрив майже більше
університетів подвійні дипломи якщо
говорити Тобто ми видаємо ви бачите тут
і від німецький Я сьогодні університет і
французький єсть і польський і так далі
І цей процес нарощується що стосується
скажімо нашої позиціювання щодо
фінансування досліджень то ми третя
четверте місце регулярно займаємо в
Україні і оце до цієї групи в
університетів якщо ви подивитесь на
рівень фінансування досліджень ми
глибоко переконані що університет 4,0
який відповідає економіки знань повинен
мати обов'язкові і наукові дослідження -
це поки рівень університету але без
штучних інформаційних технологій
цифрових технологій біотехнологій туди
мені не дійдемо ми рішення чи не рада
записали Мені все це 4:0 це звичайно
після війни Зараз ми утримуємося друга
третя позиція і так далі от ви бачите
наші дослідження ми 18-му році
стартували
з таких показників Зараз ми в цьому році
маємо Ось такі показники і таке інше
щодо стосується
публікації то ви бачите що я в 14-му
році прийшов ректором до нас їх було 95
рік в минулому році ми маємо за тисячу
таких публікацій бо ви знаєте воно не на
1 січня появляється спочатку цього року
десь за 320
приємно те що наші викладачі в цьому
році серйозно попрацювали з міжнародними
компаніями зокрема ми очолили
щодо ідентифікації вирощування
сільськогосподарських культур велику
програму по горизонту Європи і там весь
бюджет це був майже два мільйони євро а
наша частина - це на 18 мільйонів
гривень якого очолила серед бельгійських
французьких університетів ми головні
декана агрономічного факультету Оксана
торга маємо прекрасні програми з Японії
це ви знаєте фокусіма ми їм допомагаємо
нашім професій викладачі Там працюють Ну
і по размусу маємо сьогодні майже більше
4 млн кашпарово очолює проект із
Норвегії з ким університетом ну про
життя дрібні Я вам не кажу провели
зовсім недавно і вчора на спілки
ректорів я закінчую вже вчора була
спілка ректорів присутності міністра
заступників міністра не прийняли рішення
за подачу нашого університету підтримано
було про проведення
всеукраїнського бізнес-форму все це сайт
Education Business Да з тим щоб ми ми
розуміємо сьогодні без співпраці з
бізнесом з виробництвом ми нічого не
досягнемо сказав Сергій Скарлетт що
наступний рік мінус іще 12% бюджета
тобто наука та реле
матеріальна розвиток ремонти
матеріальних капітальні видатки немає
заробітня плата 12 - відсотків Тобто ми
можемо визначитися не тільки за рахунок
співпраці скажу вам відверто ми
ризикували але молодий проектору Вадим
Кондратюк 10 тут сидить
саме молодий у нас проректор Чому він
нічого не боїться Це вже я боюсь значить
і він каже давай проведем такий
бізнес-форум Ну а я себе кажу А вдруг не
прийдуть люди не відгукнуться і ми
розписуємося у своїй слабкості да
і так далі він каже Ні прийдуть ну ми
почали працювати
почали працювати скажу вам учасників
було близько 700 близько 700 було
152 компанії бізнес-контори прийшли до
нас Ну наприклад Миронівський
хлібопродукти 40 тисяч працюють
один з головних був учасників прийшли до
нас хліб України молоко компанія John
Deere кун-україна
прийшло маса людей і сюди різні потім
саме цікаво що відбулося я перше побачив
ми обычно я признаюсь по секрету
ввикаємо там пиріжки здобув вперше все
з'їли Чого ніхто після обіду ніхто не
смився і відбулося всіх засідань секцій
де укладено сотню угод рибаки зробили
погодні культури в заключили договори
скажімо там технологи енергетики
приїхали з усієї України з нашими
енергетиками автоматиками
машинобудівники приїхали значить
біотехнологи це мене дуже порадувало
харчовики всі були я скажу що значить це
мене порадувало це означало Ми отримали
в душі підтримку що ми потрібні
університетного про життя по і той
бізнес форум який ми хочемо провести за
участю нас щоб не тільки нам збирали
грантоїди і казали що ваш все погано вас
надо реформувати А коли наче учні
студенти Поїхали за кордон та також
хороший школярі Міністр освіти виступає
серед Миколай всі мені дякують за те що
школярі прийшли в 600 скільки 70 тисяч
школярів вмонтувались європейські школи
улиця хорошо А що казали грантично що ми
бездорі потім прийшли в університет
студенти тоже нормально вчаться А що
казали та не годиться все Коли я став
міністр в мене запитали як ти будеш
реформувати університети але ніяк а що
ти будеш робити Кажу заходи будуть
виконувати
нам треба три речі сьогодні завершую
перша річ яку потрібно вирішити це новий
зміст освіти а він без до цього наукових
створення нових знань досвітництва не
буде тут надо залучити Академію велику
Академію педагогічних наук велика наука
змін стає разом з нашими членами
педагогіка дає
компаративістику що вона дає
порівняльний хто вчить чоловіче а не
учить чого е-е участь американці японці
ми відбираємо на основі А третя практики
дають
підручники посібники і методику сучасну
зрозуміли друге - це
матеріально-технічна база це що ж ми
сьогодні лінія яку з Китаю возить А я
вже не кажу по прилади які в нас
Вінницькі там певні університети Я знаю
робив і багато ну маса це всього це
електронні прилади навчання
активність всякі технології і третє
Звичайно це професор викладач це його
благополуччя це його пошана і так далі І
так далі якщо він буде підготовлений то
ми все вирішили І тоді буде Європа тоді
буде Америка і все інше ми працюємо для
оборони України ми працюємо для держави
для її благополуччя тому я завжди радий
буду спільно працювати хочу подякувати
організаторам форуму нашому міністерству
за те що довірили нам і ми вас не
підведемо Слава Україні Слава нашими
збройних силам і всім освітянам головне
завдання якісна підготовка і я сьогодні
студент нам сказав Коли ви
потрапите в скрутну ситуацію ваші розум
злякається чи це буде оборона чи це буде
економіка і так далі а для того щоб ваші
розум не злякався Приходьте на заняття
ідіть дослідження ідіть гуртки дід
наукові і там ваші знання настануть
уміннями навичками і переростуть
компетенції без цього без дослідження
без науки в університеті це практику
училища
а я думаю що так нас не буде Дякую вам
за увагу Дякуємо шановний і трапився
того що ви представили ваша нове
здивування вашого університету вища
позиція у рейтингу вона дає всі підстави
вважати що усі наукові дослідження які
будуть проводитися усінах вашого
університету будуть спрямовані на
подолання тих медиків які нас зараз
супроводжують і все те що ми будемо
робити у післявоєнні відбудові І власне
ми маємо велике сподівання що ваші
дослідження дозволять нам побороти
виклики у сфері продовольчої безпеки
України заключили договори готуємо
повністю нові харчі розробляємо
заливними спеціалістами держ харчів все
по обороні і зараз працюємо навіть ми
розробляли харчі для школи оцей мені
Дякуємо Шановні колеги ми дізнаємось
чиновника та інновація є рушієм у
глобальному світі а зараз огляду на
випадки сьогодення воєнний стан боротьба
за агресором непересічні умови з якими
ми зустрічаємося
боляче за свою незалежність демократію
за можливість проводити дослідження Та є
всі підстави думати те що ми йдемо
правильним шляхом ми працюємо з нашими
міжнародними партнерами бо без їх
допомогою сьогодні нам було вкрай без
складно продовжувати ту роботу яку наші
дослідники науковці вчені інноватори
розпочали Дозвольте запросити до
вітального слова заступника міністра
освіти і науки України з питань
європейської інтеграції Олексія
Івановича шкуратора
дякую доброго дня шановні колеги Шановні
учасники нашої Міжнародної фізичної
конференції
ви знаєте що як і будь-яка конференція
сьогоднішня педагогічна конференція вона
не є виключенням це можливість зібратися
представникам влади представникам науки
представникам реального сектору Ну
сьогодні на педагогічній конференції На
жаль ми не змогли наших основних цих
колгерів це студентів і учнів запросити
у зв'язку з безпекою ситуації однак як і
будь-яка конференція перед нами стоїть
вирішення певних питань певних проблем і
звичайно сьогодні найбільша проблема У
нас це війна в нашій країні яка вплинула
повністю на всі сектори
економіки нашої країни в тому числі на
сферу освіти і науки і
наша локація вона сьогодні
зосереджена саме на проблемах науки та
інновацій без яких Як ви вже сказав
Станіслав Миколайович
університет є профтехучилищем і
неможлива ні освітня сфера ні
Наукова діяльність в жодному із закладів
освіти і тому на мою переконання сфера
науки та інновацій вона окрім того що є
складовою частиною підготовки кадрів від
наших школярів до студентів вона ще є
рушієм змін в економіці і Тому перед
нами сьогодні стоїть питання Яким чином
пережити війну в
науковцям не при цьому не втративши
людський потенціал науковий потенціал і
після її закінчення після нашої Перемоги
звичайно вкласти всі сили щоб наука та
інновації стали цим локомотивом
економіки нашої держави яким воно є в
передових країнах світу
і ви знаєте раніше звичайно ми так само
розібралися проводили конференції
вирішували певні проблеми а виявилось що
особливо та проблем та й не було в
порівнянні з сьогоднішньою існуючою яка
далі породила безліч інших е-е проблем
коли
ми подавали свій розділ до
єврокомісії у сфері освіти та науки у
нас визначили
єврокомісарів дві проблеми одна проблема
стосується освіти - це проблеми
нацменшин в нашій державі точніше сфері
освіти що недостатньо ми приділяємо
уваги Ну тут питання дискусійне а в
науці одна проблема так само недостатньо
обсяг фінансування тобто одна проблема в
державі все нам вирішити одне питання в
сфері науки тобто чітко прописано обсяг
фінансування не дозволяє нормально
відтворювати свій потенціал
тому ми сьогодні маємо зосередити всі
наші зусилля саме на тому щоб ці дві
проблеми зняти особливо
другу однак ми всі розуміємо що в умовах
війни це дуже складне питання особливо
зважаючи на те що багато наукових
досліджень потребують саме бюджетного
фінансування особливих фундаментальні
роботи
однак Незважаючи на це для нас
відкрилося певні простори для
наповнення
наших фондів зокрема спеціальних фондів
в науковій сфері з інших джерел поза
бюджетних зокрема це і
гранти наших країн-партнерів в тому
числі наших близьких європейських країн
які поруч з нами Сполучених Штатів
Америки і тому
Я переконаний що на Сьогодні має кожен
із науковців докласти максимум зусиль
щоб почати працювати з на міжнародному
рівні на Європейському на міжнародному
зробити всі дії Щоб імплементувати нашу
науку в дослідницький простір
Союзу світовий дослідницький простір
по-друге спільними зусиллями вже почати
сьогодні відбудовувати те що
агресор Російської Федерації знищила вже
в наших містах на сході в Харкові в
Херсоні
і не зупинятися продовжувати навіть
в умовах бомбардувань продовжити наукові
дослідження ви знаєте як коли
приїжджають продуктори з Харкова і
говорить що ми зробили теми зробили те
вони переорієнтували зараз свої
дослідження на оборонку тобто на виклики
сьогодення і ти розумієш що більшість
людей
під навіть ще не було там в Києві був
голодувань почали шукати безпечне
середовище це нормально будь-яка людина
хоче
переживає за своїх дітей почали
виїжджати
за кордон безпечні умови
а частина науковців залишилася на як
кажуть на фронті науковому І продовжують
ці наукові дослідження дають Можливо
навіть кажуть студентів залучають і
кажуть ви знаєте хто знав що студент
може зробити те що ми там голову такий
така ситуація що ми кажемо там раніше
могли там місяць обдумувати як же ж воно
робиться а в умовах війни за тиждень
часу зробили хлопцям на передову дали
той Дрон з тим що вони хотіли вони дали
замовлення передали без грошей без
нічого тобто зліпили там умовно кажучи з
того що було під рукою І вже хлопці
сказали Дякую і дуже багато зараз листів
надходить в Міністерства і з Міноборони
із Державної прикордонної служби те що
на сьогодні наші науковці такі
допомагають нашій країні і хочу
відмітити що недарма Ми сьогодні в
стінах одного з найпотужніших наукових
таких хабів нашої країни в університеті
про добір ресурсів природокористування
е-е і На жаль ми не змогли зібрати
велику кількість наших тому що чесно
кажучи я коли вас сьогодні побачив
зайшовши сюди е-е розуміючи що останній
е-е період тільки через екран монітора
ваші обличчя навіть тут невеликий
колектив
ту як кажуть
Косяк який ми сьогодні перебуває в Києві
і ми змогли побачити це вже дуже великий
плюс і тому я хочу всім побажати
сьогодні плідної роботи гарних доповідей
обговорень і надіюсь що спільними
зусиллями в тому числі на нашому фронті
освітянському науковому ми допоможемо
нашим хлопцям який сьогодні знаходяться
на передовій найшвидшими
темпами здобути перемогу Слава Україні
слова завершить спрямування і підтримку
науки Дякуємо що ви вболіваєте і
враження складається таке що насправді
якби у нас було достатньо фінансових
ресурсів ми могли би провести цю
кількість дослідженні які були
заплановані раніше однак Розумієте це
така ситуація що ми повинні кошти
спрямувати передусім для того щоб
забезпечити те що Україна здобула за
роки незалежності відстояти свої
демократичні цінності ми зрозуміємо
відносимося до всіх проблем які
виникають зараз у нас в країні
продуктивну позицію Шалені комунікації з
іноземними партнерами залучення допомоги
це та діяльність яку дуже активно
починаючи з 24 лютого проводить
національний фонд дослідження України
сьогодні на нашу конференцію ми
запросили виконавчий директорку цього
фонду пані Ольгу полоску і котра нам
представить ті кроки Ті дії ті напрямки
які вектори роботи ті рішення які може
на сьогодні знайти національний фонд
дослідження України для того щоб наша
наука розвивалася ще більш швидшими
темпами Прошу пані моди вам будь ласка
Дуже дякую вам пане Ігорю я в першу
чергу хочу сказати шалено
рада бачити вас всіх гріх продовжуючи
думку не тільки думкою емоційний такий
посили Олексія Івановича насправді
наразі велика кількість комунікацій
завдяки технологіям ми можемо проводити
її онлайн але оце відчуття приналежності
коли ти бачиш обличчя людей свою
колекцію просто чудова можливість тому я
дуже вдячна за організацію
сьогоднішнього закладу за те що
запросили за те що ми змогли побачити і
ще до того як я розпочну свою
презентацію Я хотіла б сказати що ми
знаходимось постійному контакті з нашими
оренду отримувачами проводимо
певні опитування і я вам хочу сказати що
цей психологічний компонент його
не можна недооцінювати і те що
перервалися певні зв'язки комунікаційні
це
дуже дуже серйозна проблема тому
насправді ці 6 місяців вже трошки більше
ніж 6 місяців для нас для фонду для
Майна особиста це місяць насправді
шаленою комунікації А І скажемо так що
як завжди в цьому житті
принципи будь-яке явище воно має
принаймні дві сторони Скажем так і ця
можливість комунікувати ця можливість
бути запрошеним бути почутим почути
думки інших Це чудова можливість а тепер
я перейду до
презентації своєї Буду намагатися швидко
поговоримо про перша частина презентації
вона буде стосуватися презентації самого
фонду а далі поговоримо про ці
нові рішення можливі рішення рішення вже
Вони мають якусь результативну складову
до яких фонд дійшов протягом цих
страшних місяців війни з самого початку
цих готових рішень ні у кого не було Ані
У нас Ані в наших іноземних партнерів
наразі гол Старший вже після першого
мабуть місяця
шовкового стану все ж таки
даймося до конструктиву
це інформація для тих хто не дуже
знається на тому чим займається
національний фонд дослідження України
для чого він був створений створений він
був за найкращими європейськими та
світовими зразками це не перебільшення
як я зараз своїм партнерами наземним
кажу ви знаєте Ми ваші родичі Можливо ви
про це не знаєте генетично з вами
пов'язані з своїми процедурами своїми
підходами
так з'явились з'явились ми нові родичі в
Україні вони радять сприймати нас в
своїй родині насправді
фонд створений був основними та ідея
була це грантова підтримка найкращих
монголо-проектів які виконуються
найкращими українськими науковцями поки
що ми реалізували проєкти з наукових
досліджень і розробок хоча в законі
нашому профільному законі України про
Наукова науково-технічну діяльність
перелік цих напрямів і від видів рандові
підтримки він ширший наразі
дуже Сподіваємось що будуть певні зміни
в законодавчому полі для того щоб ми
могли розблокувати певні з напрямків і
один з них зокрема інфраструктурні
проекти всі ми розуміємо що це дуже
важливо буде після завершення війни
відновлювати наукову інфраструктуру
маємо як зараз часто кажуть кейси навіть
того що на сході на
півдні країни в лабораторії які зокрема
гарантують кошти закупили
вони були закупити протягом 20-22-го
року торгуватись на обладнання вони ще
знищені маємо на превеликий жаль ми
маємо літаком дуже сумно статистику
те що стосується філософії взагалі
грантової підтримки знову ж таки ми не є
першопрохідцями насправді не копіюємо
але адаптуємо найкращий цивілізовані
підходи до того для того щоб підтримати
найкращі проекти найкращих науковців
треба спиратись на конкурентність і Саме
через це кошти розподіляється за
принципами
конкурсного відбору
тут екранні ви бачите основні оці
напрями грантової підтримки які законом
за нами закріплені але заблоковані
іншими поки що не
діло більшість їх заблокована іншими
нормативно-правовими актами
і ще раз скажу що на уряд дослідження
розробки основний акцент завжди робився
на цю підтримку Але я думаю що ніхто не
буде заперечувати наприклад Чи зараз в
тих умовах коли ми все частіше чуємо про
такий загрозу
відтоку мізків Brain drain і навіть про
це говорять наші іноземні партнери ми
просто не можемо не спрямувати грантову
підтримку для молодих науковців
наприклад для тієї ж інфраструктури
треба треба працювати працюємо над цим
дуже-дуже сподіваємось на підтримку
колег в цьому напрямку теж стосується
унікальності фонду в межах національних
наших межах
фонд був створений він існує для
науковців створений був науковцями і
року управлінням займається виключно
науковці У нас досить складна структура
управлінська
знову ж таки це Через те що ми хотіли
імплементувати в наших і управлінських
структурах
найкращих європейських та
північноамериканські практики
те що стосується впливу держави на те що
ми фінансуємо він може здаватись що він
мінімізований але він дуже принциповий і
ми маємо право за державну кошти
фінансувати наукові дослідження і
розробки які є пріоритетними для країни
певний час ви знаєте ще рік тому оця
пріоритетність вона була
я не скажу що умовно але ну скажемо так
спокійно всі ставились до цього наразі
часи військової агресії оця важливість
пріоритизації того на що держава може
призначати буде витрачати кошти в галузі
науки вона вже набула абсолютно іншого
значення ми маємо конкурси двох типів за
нами закріплено це права це в першу
чергу ініціативні або бутон а судовий
такий термін
в цей конкурсах Ми підтримуємо
дослідження високого світового рівня
абсолютно без будь-яких обмежень щодо
галузі що до природи навколо дослідження
тобто фундаментальний прикладній
розробки і абсолютно будь-якій галузі
Але маємо право ще і проводити так звані
тематичні конкурси - це за певним
галузевим спрямуванням знову ж таки з
такою серйозною прив'язкою до
пріоритетних напрямів дуже Сподіваємось
що якраз і за цим напрямом у нас
майбутнє Саме через ті обставини які ми
зараз з вами маємо насправді фонд був
створений і я буду брати на себе
сміливість Хоча я якраз є керівником
цієї установи можливо це краще щоб
оцінювали люди ззовні але все ж таки
візьму на роботи таку сміливість сказати
що фонд взагалі є насправді драйвером
реформ в науковій сфері саме в галузі
фінансування тому що підхід абсолютно
чіткий
груші надаються тим хто виграє на
конкурсній основі В нас дуже висока
конкуренція у нас оцей
ході за конкурсах вони трошки різний Ну
він
13-15-17%. це в принципі відповідає
європейськими світовим стандартами ви
розумієте наскільки велика конкуренція
для того щоб отримати
грам і
конкурси фонду вони в 20-21 році коли
досить високо затребувані все те що
стосується
фінансування по попередніх роках тому що
фонд на час працювати перший конкурс але
мали тільки в 2020 році ви знаєте вже
автоматично ми переводимо наші бюджети і
надаємо будь-яких презентаціях які я
гривні так і в і валюті і ви знаєте це
саме через те що дуже багато комунікуємо
з іноземними колегами тобто в нас вже це
так би мовити за замовченням в 20-му
році у нас був бюджет на підтримку 270
трошки більше 270 мільйонів гривень
значно він в
20201 році Як ви бачите да ну майже два
рази але в 2022 році з самого початку Ми
якраз перебували
у лютому в стані підписання договорів
такий період у нас договірної роботи він
місяць десь приблизно іде на початку
року коли ми вже отримаємо своєю
бюджетні призначення ви бачите що на
2020 рік сума була ще більш вражаюча
саме на ранговий підтримку 790 мільйонів
це свідчило про те що фонд набере в
обороти що держава стала довіряти фонду
більше Ну склалось Таким чином ми
розуміємо Чому ми маємо завдячувати тим
що грантове фінансування цей сезон ми
скажемо так пропустили воно призупинено
не зупинено А при зупинено наразі
докладає на всіх зусиль для того щоб з
наступного року
ми дуже добре розуміємо що до тих самих
цифр ми не повернемося до 2023 році але
покладаємо цих зусиль щоб протягом
декількох років Ми все ж таки вийшли на
достойні цифри тому що бюджетування наше
воно в межах України виглядають дуже
пристойним на 2022 рік планове в межах
будь-якої європейської країни навіть не
дуже великою за
населенням значно більше бюджету Тобто
ми маємо на цьому не зупинятись так
війна нас відкинула скажемо в часовому
такому вимірі але в будь-якому разі
додамо зусиль Я думаю що
Дай Боже за декілька років ми зможемо це
недолужити те що стосується якраз у
друго презентації до яких вже все ж таки
ми
нових рішень ми дійшли перша частина щоб
хоча б частково в 2022 році компенсувати
теж національний фонд дослідження
України наразі немає можливості
фінансувати Ані переможців 20-21 року
Ані проводити нові конкурси і
фінансувати нових переможців ми
насправді дуже серйозно шукали Ну яким
же чином ми можемо скомпенсувати те і
допомогти хоча б наших отримувачів з
якими я повторюю що ми на в постійному
контакті
з різних питань ми звертаємось до них
Вони звертаються до них знову ж таки
в цей період ми вирішили в першу чергу
Наукова рада це є один із наших керівних
основних органів Наукова рада виокремила
певну кількість проектів які мають
абсолютно точно
актуальність для вирішення як проблема
оборонозда процесу України так і
найближчих перспектив від України в
різних галузях ми звернулись до
центральних органів виконавчої влади в
Міністерства всі були ми звертались до
офісу президента
міністерством фінансів голи активну
роботу щоб цього року продовжити
фінансувати хоча б всі проекти які мають
на 100 відсоткове скажемо так
релевантність
їхні проекти мають 100% релевантність до
вирішення дуже-дуже наразі питань поки
що ну наразі ми знову ж таки з
розумінням ставимось до того що ці кошти
нам неможливо було виділити але в
будь-якому разі ми провели оцю
аналітичну роботу маємо певні заготовки
тому що 23-му році ми вже з цими
проектами однозначно можемо стартувати
те що стосується оцих проектів я
спеціально в цю презентацію назви їх не
включала Я просто хотіла щоб ви
подивились в яких саме напрямки
стосуються оті проекти які вже відібрані
наукової радою якнайбільш пріоритетні Я
не кажу що всі інші будь ласка зрозуміти
мене правильно що всі інші проекти не
заслуговують на фінансування але в
умовах обмеженого фінансування і в
умовах коли потрібні дуже швидкі наукові
науково-практичні рішення ну є певний
пол проектів Який Ну скажемо так
заслуговує на більшу увагу я не буду
витрачати ваш час просто Оце я ж кажу що
ми перерахували ці напрямки наукові які
були виокремилені Наразі по наших
проектах як першочергові
А те що стосується знову ж таки нашої
Міжнародної роботи
скажу чесно от Сьогодні ми з колегами
обговорювали те що перемовини онлайн
вони ведуться будь-який час доби тому що
різниця в часі Ми спілкуємося з нашими
колегами починаючи зі сходу це і
Австралія і Японія і завершуючи Канадою
та сполученими штатами Америки дуже
велика різниця в часі тому ми насправді
ну майже 24
години на добу іноді спілкуємось не
кожен день але дуже часто часто
дуже велику підтримку нам
надали наші колеги стосовно
інформаційної підтримки України
українських науковців
засудження
агресії Російської Федерації публічна
підтримка виключення
будь-якої співпраці з колегами
так званими колегами з Російської
Федерації з їхніх програм фінансування
ну це було були перші тижні війни
скажемо так це
ніяким чином наразі не допомагає
отримати фінансування але це ми вважаємо
також пріоритетною діяльністю те що
стосується тепер до фінансових питань
Наразі я без перебільшення можу сказати
що
так склалось що комунікаційному просторі
нашому професійному просторі ми вже
можемо назвати себе інформаційним хабом
в якому ми постійно кожен день іноді
декілька разів на день Ми розміщуємо
інформацію яка стосується або можливості
грантової бо будь-якої проектної
підтримки наших науковців яка надходить
за кордоном а наразі вже все частіше
з'являються і до нас звертаються наші
колеги за кордоном про те що вони
шукають конкретних спеціалістів або
конкретних команди які потрібні їм для
реалізації скажемо її проектів і при
цьому При цьому вони допомагають
підтримувати
українських науковців тих що залишаються
в Україні рідше І ми ведемо про це дуже
серйозні перемовини а в більшості
випадків тих хто є видушеним вимушеними
переселенцями на цьому слайді ви бачите
це знову ж таки далеко неповний переклад
перелік але це ті організації з ким ми
постійно колаборуємо як в інформаційному
полі які консультують нас і які на щастя
звертаються до нас за консультаціями
тому що з самого початку війни навіть
потреби в українських науковців були не
зовсім зрозумілі нашим колегам
в чому ми ще брали участь не так давно
вже відбулось 100 днів в цій ініціативі
з самого початку війни була
започаткована це також Бо там підхід
коли
науковці абсолютно різних галузей
представники різних організацій
зібрались і створили такий проект
ukrainianswaylored одним з надбань таких
серйозних танців проекту люди займаються
знову ж таки допомога було дуже таке
широке масштабне опитування
науковців які знаходяться на території
України які залишили вимушено залишили
Україну наразі дуже цікаві скажу
результати цього дослідження і ми
скористаємось ними коли ми ведемо
перемовини з нашими іноземними
партнерами тепер те що стосується знову
ж таки дуже дуже активно Ми співпрацюємо
з асоціацією таких же фондів як ми це
найпотужніша в Європі асоціація
команді які оперують бюджетними
державними бюджетними коштами по всій
Європі це санкції Європи Ми дуже вдячні
нашим колегам тому що цього року вони
прийняли нас
трошечки скажемо так порушивши свої
правила тому що Україна не є членом
Євросоюзу а там така вимога є все ж таки
вони зробили нам Крок вперед і прийняли
національний фонд досвідчення України
свої члени
у зв'язку з цим у нас розширилась
можливість контактувати з нашими
колегами в Європі
ініціативанс дуже важлива це німецька це
знову ж таки був там А ініціативами вони
проводять
конференції і їхня основна задача - це
так би мовити замедчити представників
однієї тієї галузі які працюють в
Німеччині в Україні просто побудувати
цей діалог а на основі цього діалогу
співпраці до головного ми тепер
автоматично входимо тому що ми є це
учасниками
членами Вибачте асоціації також дуже
дуже до війни Ми навіть не могли про це
мріяти я скажу Так
наразі ми маємо не маємо цей
привів
що можу сказати наразі сконцентрувались
на тому що все ж таки провести конкурс
хоча б індивідуальних грандів чому
індивідуальний грантів тому що ви
розумієте тут обмежений маємо обмежені
можливості по фінансуванню такий конкурс
провести фінансову легше і маю скажемо
так добре новину наразі дуже активній
розробці у нас два проекти один з них -
це з кембрівським університетом від
якого ми вже скажемо так отримали ну
певні
підписали з ними меморандум і саме
відпрацьовування
деталі і моменти цієї співпраці за кошти
кемпійського університету плануємо вже
цього уроку провести конкурс такий
перший конкурс індивідуальних гравців що
дуже важливо спрямованість цих конкурс
ніяким чином не буде мати ніякої
дискримінаційної складової це дуже
важлива завжди вимога західних партнерів
але що важливо цей конкурс буде
проведено виключно для тих дослідників
які по-перше знаходяться в Україні це
дуже важливо тому що таких
такої підтримки дуже мало зараз в світі
і по-друге це
науковці з найбільш постраждалих від
військової агресії регіонів України
а з швейцарським фондом дуже потужним
наші колеги СССР маємо таку стерню
домовленості дуже сподіваємося що
наступного року зможемо реалізувати там
вже буде конкурс спільних проектів але
на індивідуальних Ах все ж таки групових
дуже вам дякую за увагу Вибачте якщо я
перебрала свій час дуже хочу рада вас
бачити хотіла поділитись Дякую вам дякую
за те що ви представили ці нагальні
проблеми виклики які стоять передком і
шляхи якби розходити з такою сорокою
ситуацією Звісно що проблема з
фінансування і надзвичайно важливим ми
знаємо що вони насправді висушує
додаткові шляхи як заповнити цю
порожнечу яка виникла в ситуації в
Україні на сьогодні вам значної ділиться
дається також нам відомо про те що
фондум проведено А1 в проектів і серед
такої значної кількості проектів які ви
обирали за конкурсом ми побачили
величезну кількість які реалізовуються
я би тоді Шановні колеги треба бути вашу
увагу собі на цю виставку у нас тут
знаходиться два стенди і запрошує через
повторно Олексія Івановича декілька слів
сказати що це за робота Чиї це роботи і
як вони сюди потрапили Дякую
хотів сказати на рахунок
даної виставки яку ми сьогодні
презентуємо на нашій локації
трошки напевно перехвалювався забув тому
Шановні колеги ви бачите можливо тут не
досить добре видно через екран однак
хочу передати її розказати вам про що
саме це за виставка
справа в тім що наука на наше
переконання і ми бачимо що в Україні Так
воно і є починається з
дошкільного навіть віку шкільного віку у
нас є Мала академія наук де наші школярі
вже починаючи з шкільних Лав
любити науку починають пізнавати її і
далі вже практично через деякий час з
таким столом сидять вже готові
професори і
звичайно це потрібно робити і
було гарно і тепло коли
для наших дітей
які вчаться в Малій Академії Наук
з інших країн світу були такі меседжі
щодо підтримки їх в умовах агресії
Російської Федерації і сьогодні у нас є
виставка таких гарних листівок таких
картинок які підготували
дошкільнята з наукового Діскавері центру
це штат теннесі Сполучені Штати Америки
які передали нашим діткам в малої
Академії Наук які звернулися в свою
чергу до нас щоб ми зробили от на одній
із наших локацій і ми обрали локацію
науки тому що хочу наймала але вона
академія наук і тому Бачите ми
презентуємо сьогодні таку виставку з
підтримкою наших школярів наших
дошкільнят
про те що ніхто в світі не забуває про
те що у нас дійсно сьогодні є трагедія в
нашій державі і такий листи вони дійсно
спонукають
на перемогу
тому я ще раз Всім дякую за Івановича
хоч академія і мала але вона звучить
потужності Сьогодні ми всі перебиваємо
обставинах коли бомдування ворога не
припиняється коли потужні дослідницькі
наукові інноваційні центри руйнуються
коли Харків Наша перша столиця
руйнується ворогом без огляду на те Хто
там працює хто там проживає нема вибору
у ворога Чи це наукові установи чи це
університети Чи це житлові будинки і
сьогодні на нашій конференції з нами на
онлайн підключені професор Володимир
павліков про ректор науковий рух роботи
національного агротехнічного
університету імені Жуковського
Харківського авіаційного інституту пане
Володимирець Чи ви нас чуєте підтвердіть
будь ласка Шановні колеги дуже добре
чують Дуже дякую вам за те що діти таке
можливість зустрітися мінятися певним
досвідом в такий не простій частини
звичайно важливо ми маємо це всі
розуміти я з першого дня мені казав що
там основними зараз маємо не повісити
руки а думати Як будемо розвивати
економіку держави одразу після нашої
Перемоги яка обов'язково відбудеться
сьогодні підготував
докладних
керівників не скажу насправді коли Я
подавав цю тему спочатку Так вона мене
використовувалась в очах але потім коли
вже почали безпосередньо робити зрозумів
наскільки це непроста тема і як її треба
принести щоб вона дійсно
торкнулася серце кожного загалом
доповідь розігнув на дві таких великих
частини перша частина буде пов'язана
передусім стрім як на які рівні Ми
вийшли всі Я думаю не тільки хаї там на
базі Хай безумовно але загалом багато
університетів в державі вийшов на
високий рівень наукової діяльності які
ймовірно відкривались і потім друга
частина як орієнтири довелось змінити як
необхідно працювати в Нових умовах
реаліях можливо деякі напрямки Я думаю
можна буде поговорити про це я прошу
наступне слайд будь ласка
Так там якщо Ну добре Так я думаю що це
все наше життя зараз кожного розділу
нададуть такі великі частини до
24-23-23 чому це останній такий
без війни а починаючи з 24 це буде інша
частина так от досі диста структура
України
представлена це 7 наукових центрів 12
провідних проблемних науково-дослідних
людей лабораторії студентський
конструкторське бюро
науково-дослідкувати Інститут проблем
фізичного моделювання польоту літаків і
інші науці перевіряються в університеті
надзвичайно велика увага і вже я вам
скажу починаючи зі створення це в 30-му
році завжди було така Трійця це освіта
наука і обов'язково унікальні виробничі
бази свої щоб можна було одразу наукові
ідеї впроваджувати втілювати в життя і
одразу це все давати в освіту щоб
переростали Нове покоління науці
приділяємо серйозне серйозну увагу і
навіть в 21-му році було відкрито 5
нових лабораторій наступне будь ласка
завжди я вам скажу мірилом мірилом
діяльності в тому числі і Наукової
певною ціною є фінансування
покажу червона лінія загальний обсяг
залучених коштів на науку Протягом
останніх трьох років
починаючи з майже 30 мільйонів 2019 році
Це був тяжкий для країни до 20 майже 7
більше 74 мільйонів гривень які заробили
наука в 21 році тобто наука дійсно
серйозно розвивалась Ви можете бачити
серйозними такими кроками і навіть по
відношенню до 20-го року це зростання
більше ніж два рази наступні будь ласка
приведу декілька основних наших
партнерів з якими зазвичай працюємо це
безумовно Мотор Січ для якого ми робимо
найбільшу кількість
науково-дослідних робіт не буду
зосереджуватися на конкретиці якщо ми
для них робимо це стосується і
вертольотів і двигунів і навіть радари
Зараз ми починаємо разом з ними
працювати щоб встановлювати на їхнє
літак на їхній вертольоти це акціонерне
товариство Фет далі буде щодо наших
таких серйозних кроків які вже зроблені
і в результаті світового рівня які
отримані навіть у 21-му році це дівчинка
прогрес наступний будь ласка це і
Антонова безумовно наш лідер по
виробництву літаків до того ж ми
працюємо досить плідно із Китаєм У нас є
декілька робіт які ми виконуємо для
Китайської Народної Республіки безумовно
працюємо із
НАТО це програма в наука заради миру та
безпеки а також інші підприємства
наступний слайд будь ласка
наукові досягнення
вони виміряються різними чинниками але я
скажу того року
розробки хаїв які втілювались нашими
вченими А розроблялися за підтримки
знову ж таки наших вчених на
акціонерному товаристві ФЕД
вони направлені в космос відправлення в
космос це надважкий телекомунікаційний
супутник який 21 жовтня було виведено на
орбітом там якщо в інтернеті дивитися
там 21-24
спочатку йде виведення потім поки ти
під'єднаю тобто різні дати Але це був
жовтий того року такі важкі супутники це
понад 6 тонн там нова система
охолодження мала бути розробитись
загалом яка раніше не існувала і
науковці Хай реалізували ті ідеї які
спочатку у нас як кажуть видали в
повітрі 20 років назад а вже того року
це стало реальністю ви бачите тут
лабораторію зліва у нас було
організовано одразу дві лабораторії одну
хаї одну таку саму в
у Франції чимось спочатку тут
відпрацьовує відпрацьовували наші вчені
потім літали Францію і до доводили їм на
практиці що те що пропонується Воно
реально І от результатом такої плідності
праці стала те що супутники ціля і я
думаю майбутнє над важкості супутники
будуть використовувати
технології які розроблялися України
наступне будь ласка
буквально сьогодні була також додаткова
робоча нарада прийшов якраз цієї наради
щодо майбутніх розробок іоно-пазовим
двигунам знову ж таки ми плідність
співпраці разом з акціонарним
товариством Фет у якого є дуже серйозне
виробнича база і на сьогодні я скажу
мабуть був на багатьох підприємствах так
от одне з небагатьох яке майже повністю
відповідає а можливо вже відповідає
ідеології підприємства індустрії 4.0
теж знаходиться в Харкові зараз частково
релаком
змінено змінено локацію частково
частково чи залишилась так от ми
проговорили в хаї вже ми до цього вміли
виготовляти іноплазмові двигуни але
формальна формально це все іграшки чому
якщо нема повного циклу документів якщо
нема повного циклу описаний технології
дуже важко інтегруватись у те що буде в
майбутньому встановлюватись на серйозне
на серйозні тим же супутники і
направлятись в космос тому якраз така
потрібна співпраця наука і виробництво
як є міжхаї І фердом вона дозволить Я
думаю недалекому майбутньому
встановлювати наші його на плазмові
двигуни на майбутній космічні апарати
наступна будь ласка
серйозні розробки ведуться і в напрямку
[музика]
радіоелектроніки це наші електроніка ми
співпрацюємо за цим напрямком по
створенню радарів різного цільового
призначення
з багатьма підприємствами але на
сьогодні найбільш такий серйозний
замовник майбутній наш все А тема та
Мотор Січ у нас є певні гарантії того що
радар які ми будемо виготовляти вони
будуть видавати нам вертольоти під
апробування також значна увага
приділялась завжди розроблені у
безпілотних ритуальних апаратів я скажу
що в хаї вони виготовляються з 59-го
року але тоді навіть не було такої назви
безпілотної апарати називали їх
аеродинамічні
аеродинамічноподібні моделі літальних
апаратів і досвід який отримали чинність
свого часу і заклали наукові школи це ще
починаючи із u-17 су-17 потім пішли
міг-29 суд 35 всі ці літаки були в
зменшених моделях повністю обкатані
зроблені обкатані тут це перед серійним
виробництвом тобто досить надзвичайно
великий наступний будь ласка
свої досягнення скажу вам а це
лабораторія Зараз ми розробляємо
космічні радар космічного базування одна
із лабораторій де ми досліджували
радіоматеріал яким можна буде закрити
антену щоб вона не сильно спотворювала
радіосигнали не давала їм
не вносили високі затухання Я думаю що в
такий радар найближчим часом Ну не буду
зараз казати але найближчим часом
все-таки вдасться запустити космос і у
нас буде ще в космос і не тільки система
охолодження але і радари дистанційного
зондування Дякую наступний будь ласка
свої свої досягнення ми В тому році
представляли на декілька серйозних
виставках це одна із них це Авіас від 21
ми тут можете бачити і однофазний двигун
і макети безпілотних літальних апаратів
які
розроблялись з урахуванням максимального
зниження
помітності в оптичному радіо
інфракрасному і акустичному діапазонах
так і радари і інші розробки наступний
будь ласка
Нам того року вдалося прийняти участь
навіть виставки на виставці Саха Експо
це Туреччина досить серйозний
моя Виставковий потенціал там можна
заключати певні контракти на майбутнє в
складі української делегації якраз був
хаїту також представлений безпілотником
справи можна бачити в правому кутку І
його на плазмовими і плазмового ігунними
двигунами це трішки різні типи двигунів
Дякую може наступним
всі ці роботи і певна Довіра на
міжнародній арені знову ж таки дозволила
нам вийти на першу позицію
Харківський національний інститут на
першу позицію за коштами які залучені
Україною за програмою горизонт 2020 якщо
тут придивитись То якраз перша позиція
ми знову вийшли на лідери належить
національному аерокосмічному
університеті Річ у тому що на сьогодні
ми виконуємо 7 проєктів і декілька
вимушені були призупинити тимчасово
пов'язана це з тим що у нас
нема дозволу на роботу з прекульсорами
там то лоує з яким з монокристолом
домовились нам треба установку яку ми
розробили заправити і випробувати але на
сьогодні ми написали призупинений
тимчасово Я думаю як тільки буде
можливість ми відновимо ці роботи але
така можливість попри зупинення робіт
вона передбачена наступна будь ласка
і тут уже на початок 22-го року я вам
скажу хай було чітко виключно на перелік
перспективних розробок які ми мали самі
реалізувати частково за власні кошти
частково за кошти інвесторів і інші це
легкий двомісний літак Навіщо це було
потрібно зараз Україні надзвичайно
потрібен літаки первинної льотної
підготовки ні такий недорогий двомісний
літак легкий якраз У нас уже сформована
конструкторське бюро і пішли розробки і
навіть я вам скажу частину деталей ми
вдалось нам закупити на початку цього
року це радари космічного базування
продовжується робота сімейство
безпілотних літальних апаратів зараз я
не буду в уточнювати яких але
є і ідеї і напрацювання радари для
вітчизняних гелікоптерів
іноплазмові двигуни технології
устаткування для формування захисних
покриттів це система також технологій
кіберзахисту критичних інфраструктурок
на цим всім ми працювали у нас були
серйозні плани на цей рік наступний будь
ласка
але наступило 24 лютого і ми трішки мали
змінити наші виклики і орієнтири я скажу
коли почав дивитися
орієнтирів дуже багато Але скажу перший
ринкер для нас всіх - це став безумовно
потреби збройних сил а вона якої
ємній продукції безумовно Це пов'язане з
певним високоточним озброєнням від
технікою яка потрібна Я кажу наші
науковці вони запросто можуть працювати
безумовно з інших університетах це і зі
стрілецькими озброєннями саме
проєктувати є гарні фахівці із
газидинаміки це створна
артилерії Вибачте І Арсена і ракетне
озброєння Можемо проєктувати і я вам
скажу досить тривалий час перед цим пару
ну років зо два Я їздив і намагався
через Міністерство оборони домовитись
щоб увійти в держзамовлення і все але
там дуже непрості ці це І літаки і
безпілотники і протипові міжнародна
оборона і що на сьогодні стало
надзвичайно актуальним це протиракетна
оборона тому що системи протиповітряної
оборони Це дуже добре розумію тому що ну
певні є досвід і протиракетної оборони
це зовсім інші спеціальні системи і раді
електронного розвідка і радіо електронна
боротьба але тут я скажу як тут якщо
дивитись так в розрізі держави то А як
тут не говорити про полігу медицину Я
знаю що в закладах вищої освіти є
серйозні здобутки щодо того як в
польових умовах там створювати як краще
е-е обробляти рани
загоювати і далі це і системи
індивідуального захисту які беззв'язок і
спецзв'язок це все дійсно надзвичайно
високі
і тому мають стати безумовно орієнтирами
нашими Це мається на увазі науковці
мають на це орієнтуватися і змінювати в
певним чином свої роботи я вам скажу що
сьогодні я не буду проводити прикладів
як змінилися свої напрямки ми тому що це
серйозне питання це можна говорити буде
тільки після війни але в державі має
бути таке розуміння Я думаю що ті сидять
Зараз я їх бачив То вони мабуть це також
дуже серйозно розуміють і долучилися до
таких розробок наступне будь ласка
фактично на сьогодні головними
замовниками
Я думаю що не тільки для нас а для нас
всіх це стало збройні сили це управління
Головне управління розвідки і зовнішній
розвідка і всі розвідки і служба безпеки
і держка саме на них ми маємо зараз і
орієнтуватися і витрачати кошти наступне
Але скажу дуже важливо розуміти що є і
потреби все-таки все ж таки і цивільного
населення вона як наука євній продукції
цей медицина і продовольчий безпека
сьогодні надзвичайно актуальна я
[музика]
нещодавно також відкривав карту дивився
як зруйновані поля під Харків Ну не
тільки під харками багатьох місцях там
живого місця на полях не залишається
після серйозних обстрілів за цей час це
серйозні втрати в майбутнє тому що не
можна просто взяти і потім переорати Це
поле я скажу є переродиться поле і потім
посадити там щось виросте це серйозний
процес до якого має бути долучені
науковці і також допомагати вирішувати
проблеми
рекультивації за менше як правильно
назвати це є біобезпека і енергобезпека
я не знаю як взагалі буде проходить
наступна зима настільки була складною ця
попередня зима Але ж ми тільки там
місяць її заставили умовно А яка буде
наступна зима коли Ворог буде бити по
об'єктам критичної інфраструктури
все це питання також важливо вирішувати
і можливо навіть і не відкладати їх на
майбутнє
наступна будь ласка
тому я хочу сказати що на сьогодні наука
через інновації Вона має стати рушієм
механічного економічного розвитку Але
коли так кажу то я чітко розумію що На
сьогодні це поки що це тільки гасло але
треба перейти до того щоб це було
певним через певну політику державницьку
щоб це стало
руководством до кого експлуатації і щоб
ми все-таки відновлювали нашу економіку
тому що іноді я дивлюсь наших як
виступають депутати Коли їм задають
конкретне питання Як ви будете
розбудовувати економіку це звичайно
немає готових рішень Я розумію що це
важкі рішення але все ж таки в умовах
всього має стояти наука сьогодні якраз я
переглянув стратегію інноваційного
розвитку України до 2030 року і там
написано що в основі всього буде
покладено це вчені і юридичні особи до
яких вони належать Це університет який
наукові установи виклики Шановні колеги
я вже завершую виклики які ж виклики
викликів дуже багато і також їх
підсумувати дуже складно але те що
зіштовхуються майже кожного дня мабуть
проректор і як організатор наукової
роботи декілька я виніс не буду цей
виконання взятих на себе зобов'язань
перед мон та замовниками господарчих
робіт скажу що на сьогодні в країні
призупинено ні одної роботи яку ми
виконуємо
договором це виконання взятих на себе
зобов'язань перед міжнародними
партнерами тому що Це також важливо якби
складно не було але ми маємо виконати
чомусь саме на горизонт 2020 Звертаю
увагу тому що разом 2020 зараз
припиняюсь своє існування з далі буде
горизонт Європа і уже нема куди
відтерміновувати виконання цих проектів
важливе питання сьогодні стоїть - це
організація логістичних мереж проведення
наукових досліджень я дякую декілька
деяким про ректорам з якими я
зв'язувався після початку війни і просив
щоб прийняли декількох науковців
наприклад це молодих хлопців аспірантів
і не просто що по одному а цілу групу їх
розстріляти давали їм
контрольно-вимірювання апаратуру
допомагали Їм Вони там сиділи працювали
в безпечних регіонах України Хоча можна
так в умовно безпечно на сьогодні велика
проблема це закупівлі матеріальних
комплектуючих та обладнання я скажу коли
ми почали працювати на ті структури які
я раніше показував то
стала проблема Ми не можемо майже нічого
купити все що електроніка все воно
попадає під потенціал подвійного
застосування і нам не хочуть його
продавати просто так це і ми шукаємо
логістичні різні шляхи як поставити
Україну те чи інше те що раніше можна
було вирішити протягом двох тижнів зараз
йде півтора місяці Тобто це також
виклики перед нами
як добуватись
допомагати питання яке сьогодні турбує
мабуть кожного проектора - це
відсутність доступу до використання для
використання тих закупівель коштів
спецфонду ви знаєте що є потужне
обмеження - це постанова КМУ 590 і
фактично ми можемо тільки зарплату з них
заплатити а будь-який матеріал це ми
купити не можемо Тому це треба
вирішувати це серйозний виклик з якими я
також прошу звертаюсь до Міністерства
треба допомагати на порозі в нас тут
писання держзамовлення на сьогодні у нас
є потенціал залучити серйозні кошти під
серйозні розробки які ми можемо здати за
за 4-6 місяців але ці кошти заходять
виключно як спецфон і використати ми їх
не зможемо тому звертаюсь про шуруп до
вимогу дуже Всім дякую за увагу Слава
Україні
[музика]
Дякуємо за те що ви у таких непростих
умовах продовжувати свої дослідження
Дякуємо за те щоб котре сконцентрували
увагу всіх присутніх та конференції що
навкоємність внутрішнього продукту
України повинна зростати і недаремно ви
сьогодні послалися одна стратегію
розвитку сфери інноваційної діяльності
тому що цей документ розроблявся великою
курортою вчених інновація науковців у
тому вигляді який він був прийнятий
урядом це є наш дороговках щодо вашого
питання яке ви піднімали стосовно 590
постанови Кабінету Міністрів України
Міністерство надіслало свої пропозиції
до Міністерства фінансів для того щоб ми
могли поможливити усім аплікантам які
звертаються до банківських інституцій
через казначейському використати ці
кошти на сьогодні це питання ще потребує
певного доопрацювання але усі зусилля
які ви докладаєте вони не лише тамарними
тому що Міністерство активно працює над
тим щоб полегшити вам використання ви
можете з банківських рахунків за
системою казначейських платежів Дякую
вам ще раз і я пригадую цей момент коли
на одній бюджетних комісій на бюджетному
комітеті ми розглядали інвестиційний
проект який стосувався аеродинамічної
труби на базі вашого університету і коли
усі депутати Одноголосно проголосували
про підтримку цього проекту тобто
розуміння того що робить Ваш університет
Які дослідження воно є і ми будемо усі
разом намагатися вирішити питання для
наукової спільноти України для того щоб
все ж таки вишукати можливість
фінансувати ті Дослідження які є вкрай і
критично необхідними Україні особливо
зараз Дякую вам ще раз Миру вам Бережіть
себе наука заради миру
Ми продовжуємо нашу роботу і я хочу
звернути увагу на те що дуже багато
нових ініціатив зараз зароджується і
одним із драйверів таких ініціатив є
рада молодих учених при міністерстві
освіти і науки України останні їхня
ініціатива яка спонукала до бурхливих
ресурсів - це офіс підтримки вченого
покликана вирішити ряд питань тому
спільно із ради молодих учених
Міністерства освіти і науки України
склалося екшн-план ми видали достатню
Кількість завдань і Цей список він буде
все збільшуватися і збільшуватися тому
що ваші ідеї вони породжують і у нас
людей і ми бачимо як ми можемо стильно
працювати Дозвольте запросити до слова
голову ради молодих учених України
доктора юридичних наук професора пані
Олеся Ващук Сьогодні вона поділиться
своїми думками з приводу того як
педагогіка і які результати наукові
можуть бути впроваджені у практику
запрошую пані олесик дякую Я сьогодні з
пропозицією одною великою В нас є новий
проект це черговий проект такий без вас
ніяких не втілимо і тому важливо нам
цьому край потрібна
наша сьогоднішня конференція вона перш
за все Серпнева педагогічна тому освіта
освітяни незламній війні Це дійсно так
бо
саме
тримаючи кожен свій фронт ми тримаємось
тримається наша країна і я сьогодні буду
говорити про те Які в нас вже є наразі
педагогічні дослідження
які зараз проводяться які вже є надбання
які готові до впровадження дійсно їх
перелік вражає і кількість вражає
глибина та зміст і вони вже наразі не
просто готові до провадження а з
мінімальними ресурсами до їх провадження
єдине питання що не всі мають або час
або доступ до цих досліджень або ж вони
знаходяться в такому ракурсі що багато
хто хотів би їх впроваджувати немає
можливості це зробити що ми будемо
намагатися зробити якщо казати ми будемо
намагатися впровадити їх практику шляхом
їх популяризації тобто тих результатів
наукових розробок в педагогіці і тих
дослідники зараз проводяться і глобальне
мета не тільки їх популяризація та
впровадження практику а можливо зміни
тих досліджень які Зараз проводиться на
актуальні теми які потрібні саме зараз
не тільки після війни набагато говоримо
про відновлення після війни Проте ми
наголосили на те що зараз війна і нам
треба ще й зараз Вижити після війни теж
будуть виклики і можливо вони навіть
зміняться але наразі Ми стоїмо над тим
що зараз треба вижити і ті на роки які
вже є які вже готові які достойні того
щоб їх проваджувати треба цим
користуватися тому Радимо молодих вчених
є ті інституті яка стартувала в нас є
певний досвід Тобто ми не просто виникли
і пропонуємо кажемо що ми це зробимо
можна зробити ви бачите на стенді
скільки ми вже робимо і вони всі ці
проекти всі ці ініціативи реалізовані і
реалізуються Тобто це не разово якісь
дії які не мають
подальшого провадження та результатів А
ось через офіс ми пропонуємо цей проект
впроваджувати Чому через офіс бо якщо
казати через Раду бо будемо обмежений
тільки дослідження молодих вчених А ми
знайшли над цікаві Дослідження які
проводять досвідчені вчені і їх варто
впроваджувати це неймовірний Пул
результатів готові до впровадження і
якими вже можна зараз працювати
на слайді ви бачите ті напрямки які вам
буде займатися офіс і один з напрямків
який буде направлений Саме цей проект
проект який називається До речі в нас
науково-педагогічні кейси це саме
популярніться будуть займатися в цьому
напрямку і чотири великі напрями цей
інноваційні напрямки вони будуть
стосуватися по сферам бачите новації в
дошкільній освіті виклики початкової
школи перспективи розвитку середньої
освіти практичні аспекти педагогіки
вищої школи
чому окремо Тому що ті напрацювання які
є вони теж діляться за напрямами До речі
хтось може сказати що недостатньо
роздільно треба ще ділити можна
погодитися А можна поки залишитися на
цих чотирьох напрямах і з них розпочати
далі вже буде видно яким чином ми будемо
їх ділити або навпаки узагальнювати
наразі вже розповсюджений листи
звернення до ректорів які мають
себе результату таких науково-досліджень
з проханням до 24 вересня доєднатися але
це надзвичайно з кінцеві термін Будемо
далі його продовжувати з тим
напрацюванням хто з чинник бажає і їх
популяризувати якщо ви знайдемо в мережі
Інтернет наприклад на ходу дослідження
тобто результат все ситуаційне
дослідження начебто воно цікаве Дуже
добре але якщо вчений не забажає нам
допомогти його популяризувати виступити
зробити лекцію записати з ним відео
розмістити в мережі потім якщо якийсь
заклад освіти дитячий садок цікавиться
зробити для них презентацій розігріти що
він саме ма увазі що він хотів А коли
почнеться впровадження То може щось
змінити знаєте що додати щось прибрати
щось навпаки до розробити і надати цьому
закладу щоб було актуальне провадження і
мала зміст так без цих вчених ми не
зможемо це робити тому ми Звернулися до
всіх ректорів ініціювати хто забажає
долучитися цього проекту і
популяризувати свої на здобутки і
теперішньої надбання у сфері педагогіці
ми настоялись осторонь ми вже самі дещо
вже обрали якщо казати про дошкільну
освіту що ми маємо цікаве до цих
фахівців ми вже теж звернулися особисто
з проханням доєднатися бути готовим до
того щоб разом з ними будем займатися
промоційними активностями Щось цікаве є
інтерактивні методи навчання Ну нічого
дивного Але там є дещо таке цікаве До
речі з програмами де розробники є наші
українці і вони є безкоштовним до
використання їх легко можна застосувати
в діяльності далі голова освітня
діяльність вона більше розповсюджується
і причому в різних формах в тому числі
використання
3D окулярів і різних форматах інших
окуляри будуть додаткової реальності
форма роботи з дошкільнятами і все
більше і більше стає але чому більше
стає тому що діти змінюються і діти
вимагають вже нових форм роботи якщо
могли зацікавити 5 років дитину одної
форми навчання То зараз вона може не
працювати ця форма і кожні Діти теж
мають свою особливості в тебе ці форми
постійно вдосконалювати далі діяльність
дітей в дитячому садку Якщо раніше
більш-менш було ставлена графіки і чим
вони будуть займатися То наразі це вже
трошки не відповідає дійсності і вимогам
самих дітей вже навіть діти отримуючи
вдома від батьків певні накал
інструментів для розвитку вже в дитячому
випадку цього не бачить що вони цього
вимагають і тому батьки вже приносять Ну
я думаю що наші ці садки повинні самі
ініціювати і бути передовими в цьому
процесі програма розвитку дітей Вони теж
різні і типи дитячої садків дітей в нас
дуже добре що багато з кожним з них
стається більше от садка у нас були
проблеми навіть майже в дії впроваджена
можливість буде ставати в чергу це ж
додатки є проблема Але можливо буде
вирішенням саме не кількість садочків а
типів і це вирішить питання бо не всі
наприклад батькам треба дітей залишати
дитячим садочку на повний день Тобто це
як приклад як варіант
виклики початкової школи що вже є з чим
можна працювати Це ключові
компетентності нової української школи
ми знаємо що нова українська школа
активна впроваджується і має схвальний
відгуки не тільки від батьків дітей а й
на міжнародному рівні проведені непогані
вже аудити він не володіння державною
мовою як не Здавалося б дивним але про
це теж є рекомендації саме для
початкової школи здатність спілкуватися
рідною мову іде іноземними мовами бачимо
рекомендації вона є
математична компетентність це як ми собі
задаємо питання Скільки 580 місць в
нашій країні в цьому році да І скільки
було пода заявок це правда 150 тисяч
Тобто
це дуже важливо
є вільному доступі І якщо все ж таки нас
ще не дозволить користуватися і сам ви
собі було б дуже цікаво права такі
методики які він пропонує компетентність
у галузі природничих наук техніки
технологій екологічна компетентність
Інформаційна комунікаційна
компетентність бачите компетентність
вони всі беруть ширко тобто вміння
навички та знання навчання продовжується
щоб діти розуміли знаєте як дехто До сих
пір тлумачить що треба обирати навчання
да або закінчиш коли вже більше нічого
робити не будеш ну не працюють давно і
це дітям треба починати говорити з
початкової школи тобто навчання
продовжиття громадське та соціальні
компетентності культурна компетентність
без цих складових Нікуди і при цьому
дитина повинна бути соціально активна і
можливості цієї соціальної активності що
вони не заважали його на вчинню
наприклад або до зуботіннішого
компетентності підприємливість Та
фінансово-градентність це не так вже є
її Скажімо так для нас вже не знайомим і
ми повинні про це говорити Вже з
початкової школи і організація взаємодії
вчитель учнів батьки і громадських і
багато було дуже робіт щодо нових форм
далі ми з вами підемо
педагога Але це вже ще до середньої
школи педагоги Коуч фасилітатор
модератор деякі школи з метою економії
засобів в одному вчителі все це
впроваджують де ті навпаки дуже дрібно
дивляться і причому деякі плутають
хто що повинен робити Я й таке але
інновації є і вони стосуються як
управління таких роботи з особливими з
овочами освіти вони стосуються
формування Soft Skills про які ми
говоримо йде така знаєте навіть
боротьба між хаскі соски особливо перед
викладачами при навантаженні але Soft
Skills м'які навички - це тренд ринку
праці без цього нікуди при цьому їх
можна здобувати не обов'язково В урочний
клас от як по цій праці є рекомендації
по здобутті їх позаурочний клас і Можна
з цим скористатися тобто щоб наші діти
мали особливість чому іноземці зараз і
кажуть що наші діти дуже освічені тому
що в них багато є хаскілз вже здобути
компетентності
комплексне вирішення проблем та і
середньоосвітні вони є уміння керувати
людьми взаємодія з людьми емоційний
інтелекти і багато цих праць якраз
виділено можливостями викладачів
розвиватися і час на це вміння формувати
власну думку та приймати рішення до речі
от в цьому напрацюванні йде про
відповідальність і що кожен кожен
кожен учасник освітнього процесу повинна
себе брати певну відповідальність як
дитина батьки школа викладач
рекомендую орієнтація на клієнтів
причому у нас учень з одного боку
виступає теж клієнтам і це треба
розуміти але він як клієнт повинен бути
теж свідомо і не стояти тільки на
вимагання або тому я хочу так повинна
бути щодо педагогіки вищої школи Що
готове в нас до провадження інноваційні
технології навчання
особливості офлайн нового та онлайнового
навчання Ми мабуть
неодноразово ми були учасниками багатьох
конференції на яких ми говоримо про
тренди зараз про інновації навчальні як
це впроваджувати знаєте дуже нормальні
речі говорять єдине що мене завжди лякає
що це проговорили і в тих втекли по
своїм закладом освіти і все тиша завжди
ми вимагаємо резолюції завжди ми маємо
цю резолюцію виконувати розповсюджувати
і в подальшому намовляти не слідкувати
щоб було цей резолюцією виконано бо
дійсно є гарно напрацювання і єдине що
вони і бувають якісь урізаний характер
часткових характер і в подальшому якщо
їх не розвивати не доводити до
конкретного споживача вони будуть Ну
затухати і не користуватися попитом тому
багато чого є вивчій школі і за цим Якщо
це не популяризувати Якщо це не
просувати і не використовувати на
практиці вищої школи то дуже маленька
ерогідність того що вони будуть
впроваджені і наша Вища школа буде
цікавою
завершуючи що ми зараз пропонуємо ми
пропонуємо в цьому проекті педагогічні
здобутки двокрапка впровадження кейси
пропонуємо промоцію та просування самих
наукових результатів з педагогіки з
метою впроваджень найбільш необхідних
практику і стимулювання нових
затребувань тобто те що в нас є наразі
Вже готове і те що Зараз проводиться
можна зробити аналіз того що є просувати
намагатися впровадити впроваджувати
отримувати результати А те що вже Зараз
проводиться намагатися підкоригувати під
потреби бо зараз війна І можливо це
треба і додати і до методології навчання
і до методики до прийомів треба щось
змінити не щось А конкретно отримати
рекомендації при цьому це у зараз у час
коли продовжує свою навалу росіяни їхня
орда а вже після війни Я думаю що кожен
з нас із педагогіки маєш вже такий
досвід і готуємо з вересня місяцем
проєктом і маючи вже як кажуть досвід
того щоб користуються попитом вони самі
підкоргують що треба що не треба здобуде
такого таку знаєте досвід того що треба
щось змінювати щоб бути корисним Окей
зараз це треба а зараз ти а після війни
можливо це буде Давайте вже почнемо
досліджувати будемо впроваджувати тому
пропонуємо свої послуги ми відкриті
готові долучайтеся хто чує хотіла дуже
подякувати тим хто зараз бачить тим хто
побачить після наша і зможе про нього
говорити долучайтеся Ми відкриті готові
наші контакти Всюди є і будь-яка ваша
пропозиція не залишиться не те що просто
вголос вказаною а вжитою і ми
обов'язково над не попрацюємо тому
педагоги Дякуємо вам що ви вже наробили
і сподіваємося ми зможемо це просунути
впровадити практику і до речі коментар
це не означає що за наразі нічого не
було впровадження впроваджено багато
чого з того що пропонується впроваджено
і працює і ми бачимо наших дітей про які
відгукуються п міністр добре працює це
ми кажемо про подальшу популяризацію і
розвиток і якщо ви нам допоможете
прийдете до нас дозволити працювати з
вашим матеріалами то я думаю разом ми
зможемо Набагато набагато більше дякую
дякую
ваша доповідь вона така дуже мотивуюча і
коли ми згадуємо про те що зараз також
народжується дітки і тоді під відео
Другої світової війни це діти війни але
ми для них представили певне бачення
певну модель я це відразу проектую на
інноваційні технології підходи і в мене
перед очима кружева світиться Наш новий
проект А в школі
але це на рівні садочок почнемо далі я
свій садочок школа університет все те
викликає в майбутньому наших школярів
для прогресивного навчання сьогоднішня
дитина вона вже давно отримала
сертифікація правової грамотності рівня
1:0 давно вона вже це отримала
літні підходи всі технології сучасні про
які ви згадували дають можливість нам
виховати потужного майбутнього науковця
ми плавно перейдемо від дитячої освіти
від педагогіки до освіти здобуття
наукового ступеня Я хочу запросити до
слова парні професор токстарному пані
Ганна телефон є проректоркою наукової
роботи національного університету імені
Тараса Шевченка і вона нам представить
дуже цікаву модель модель спільного
здобуття ступеня доктора філософії яка
має широко ресурсів яку в Європі причому
Хочу звернути вашу увагу що саме така
модель навчання вона є абсолютно
безпечною важким в умовах військової
агресії Прошу пані професор вам слово
Дуже дякую Ігор Михайлович насправді я
дійсно представлю реальний інструмент
яким я дуже хочу поділитися тому що у
нас є напрацювання і коли мене
запитали з доповіді я хочу виступити ми
будемо говорити про руші змін я обрала
таку назву котютель рушій змін системи
підготовки докторів філософії Чому це
так тому що доктор філософії це наш
аспірант
він і є основною рушійною силою
збереження наукового потенціалу
людського потенціалу нашої держави і є
рушійною силою взагалі науки в Україні
Кожен науковий керівник дуже радіє коли
в нього є дуже гарний аспірант на цьому
слайді Ми представили результати Які
були опубліковані на зяву станом на 2021
рік Я дуже сподіваюся що ці показники не
будуть
зменшувати з часом будуть
збільшуватись і ми бачимо що у нас саме
закладах вищу освіти готуються переважно
більшість
докторів філософії тому саме на нас з
вами на освітянах лежить сама головна
відповідальність за підготовку за
утримання цих кадрів звісно ми і всі про
це говорили я не перша Я тільки можу
підтримати що міжнародна спільнота увага
міжнародна прикута до академічної науки
До закладів вищої освіти
дуже багато ми отримуємо допомоги дуже
Ми багато отримаємо звернень і дуже
багато ми отримуємо пропозиції виступити
з доповіді там де ми можемо розказати
про реальні наші потреби і не
виключенням є рада докторської освіти
про європейська асоціації університетів
До речі спілка ректорів цього року нашої
держави вперше стала також повноправним
членом Це є дуже важливим європейською
асоціацією університетів це дає нам
певні інструменти і доступ до реформ до
інформації і окремо була в Манчестері
сесія яка була присвячена докторах
дюкіни
я мала честь там також робити доповідь
але я не буду казати про свою доповідь я
хотіла зосередити увагу на доповіді
Олександра березкого він є науковцем і
ми також цим пишаємося з тим що він
цього року був обраний президентом
євродок євродок - це спілка рад молодих
вчених Європи Вони мають своє лобі
Брюсселі вони впливають на політику і це
також дуже важливий крок для України і
Олександр Бориско він зробив опитування
питання сидить Олеся Ващук вона
улибається тому що посміхається тому що
вона також допомагала Я знаю готувати цю
доповідь і мені є посилання тому кому це
цікаво Я
рекомендую ознайомитись на сайті євродок
він зробив реально опитування
кейсів молодих вчених з різних регіонів
України саме аспірантів він
зробив дуже цікаві висновки про те які є
потреби які є виклики ці виклики вони
дуже співпадають з тими викликами які
публікують різні заклади вищої освіти
наукові установи не виключенням є наш
університет Київський національний
університет імені Тараса Шевченка я їх
намагалась тут зробити уваги перше - Це
звісно людський потенціал це перший
виклик тому що ми знаємо що біля 15
відсотків аспірантів вони є переміщеними
можна внутрішні так і закордоном про те
переміщенні їх наукові керівники що
також ускладнює їх процедуру захистів і
виконання їх освітньої наукової
складової але для мене було прикро коли
я за результатами нашого опитування
дізналась що серед цих 15% Лише 10%,
вони знайшли собі місце в Європі і чи в
Америці Чи туди куди вони були
переміщені і вони можуть продовжувати
своє навчання це дуже-дуже низький
відсоток решта просто знаходиться
там і немає можливості продовжувати своє
навчання в аспірантурі потім ми
зацікавилися провели аналіз кількості
заяв на тимчасове переривання навчання
тобто Академічна відпустка
2021 рік період з 24 лютого і до червня
і
2022 рік я була вражена що кількість цих
заяв зросла три рази Тобто це показник
того що ми можемо втратити взагалі в цих
аспірантів вони можуть до нас не
повернутися окрім звісно людського
потенціалу Ми повинні зважати на те що у
нас відбувся секвестр те що сьогодні
доповідала Ольга Олександрівна полецька
100% був
секвестрований бюджет на проекти які
виграні
від національного фонду дослідження
України
бюджетне фінансування Від міністерства
осві науки на науку в університеті також
зазнав дуже значного зареєстрування А це
основа для фінансування
наукових досліджень аспірантів тому що
на сьогоднішній день навчання в
аспірантурі передбачає лише стипендії і
якісь мінімальні кошти на оплату
освітницьких послуг які надає
університет тому кожен науковець кожен
науковий керівник вишукує гранти і це
правильно і він не може дати цієї
можливості сьогодні також 100% було
секвестровано все що стосується
капітальних видатків тобто розвиток
нашої інфраструктури він також зазнав
певних негативних той
звісно змушує нас переглядати засади
підготовки докторів філософії і я вважаю
і коли я спілкувалась за кордонними
колегами це як з'ясувалось найвразливіша
категорія ми отримуємо дуже багато
звернень
проції що ми готові прийняти ваших
вчених ми готові
забезпечити студентів але жодного
звернення що ми готові забезпечити
аспірантів не було коли я виступала на
різних
платформах і говорила про це
що Так в цьому є проблема І тепер ці
фонди вони на наступні бюджетні періоди
будуть розглядати можливість і для для
аспірантів і для їх окремої підтримки І
от таким інструментом який як мені дуже
сподобалась представили Ігор Михайлович
він є дійсно безпечно дійсно він є
безпечним Чому без безпечним Тому що
перед нами стоїть задача А це
забезпечити виконання
науково-освітньої складової аспірантів
які навчаються і в
залишити привабливою аспірантуру в
Україні особливо для природничих
спеціальностей це Наша задача шукати
нові інструменти
котютель - це такий договір який
укладається безпосередньо для аспіранта
індивідуально для нього індивідуально
для його освітнього наукової програми
перше він був запроваджений
міністерством освіти і науки Франції в
1994 році Наразі це процедура вона дуже
активно популяризується і розвивається
розвиваються в Європі вона дає
можливість мати два наукових керівники в
Україні і закордонному закладі вищої
освіти також чітко визначається що робе
аспірант
кожному з закладів вищої освіти Чи
наукової установи також чітко
визначається як буде формуватись разова
спеціалізована де буде відбуватися
захист і головне що за результатами
навчання в такій аспірантурі а
спірант одного захисту
захист може отримати два дипломи нашої
країни і країни де проводився
навчання звісно ініціаторами котютелей є
перш за все керівник може бути тому що в
нього є Може бути сам аспірант він може
це ініціювати тому що коефітель
підписується вже після того як
аспірантступив до закладу вищої освіти
Чи наукової установи ну і звісно
університет але відсоток дуже низький
переважно це керівник і аспірант Ну я не
буду зупинятись на перевагах ПО тютелі
для університету Це для мене як для
проректора з наукової роботи
головне - це те що є прикладом
справжньої дієвої угоди тому що ми дуже
багато часу підписуємо угод які потім
залишаються лише угодами а ці угоди
можуть працювати І це такий Ботом Up
коли аспірант є містком між
закладом вищої освіти однієї держави і
іншої держави Він молодий Ініціативний
мотивований це дуже потужний місток
Я говорю не просто так я хочу
підтвердити що університет Шевченка має
дуже серйозну історію і досі таких
котютелях починаючи з 1999 році в нас
був перший захис за спеціальністю на
людину в 4-10 фізика набір провідників
від диелектрика разом з центром Ліон
Франція науковий керівник з крешевський
від нашого був університету
2016-20 років ще п'ять аспірантів
закінчили спільну аспірантуру і наразі
тут є інформація про те і 9 угод
переважно у нас є основним партнером
нашим францем але ми розширюємо
географію Норвегія
і так далі
Те що я зазначена що
рада докторських шкіл
Європи
дуже активно до цього долучається є
підтвердженням того щоб було в травні і
квітні 2022 року оприлюднені їх
дослідження в яких взяли участь 23
університети з 15 країн Європейського
Союзу і вони ділились своїм досвідом як
у них перебігають котителі які є
проблеми у них які є позитивні зрушення
цього я хочу сказати що однозначно за їх
висновком Вони свідчать про те що це є
важлива складова стратегічна
інституційного плану з відповідним
розподілом ресурсів та чіткими
інструкціями є це дієвий інструмент
співпраця для інституційного розвитку та
інтернаціоналізації і кожен університет
повине це розглядати Звісно що для того
щоб це працювало для цього потрібні
певні правові засади Я хочу сказати що
трансформація підготовки взагалі раніше
це було кандидати на тепер це доктор і
філософії тобто підготовка аспірантів це
трансформація кому спостерігаємо з 2005
року коли Україна підписала участь
балонського процесі і Коли в 2016 році у
нас стартувала вже підготовка аспірантів
через систему
структуровано аспірантури а саме
докторів
філософії також те що у нас дозволена і
унормована Академічна
мобільність - це нам дуже багато
розв'язує руки тут перераховані всі та
нормативні акти які нам дають можливість
його останній який був оприлюднені в
січні 2022 року і по якому ми повинні
дуже працювати Скажімо так в умовах дуже
складних які зумовлені війною Ми повинні
цей процес були запускати і все
постанові зазначимо що аспіранту може
бути призначена два наукових керівника
що нам дозволяє реалізовувати котютелі
кого членами одноразової спеціалізованої
ради можуть бути А іноземний реце
нзент B2 опоненти можуть бути також
іноземцями Головне щоб вони були
фахівцями за темою дисертаційного
дослідження Також мова зараз то може
бути як Українська так і англійська І
саме дисертація дисертація може бути
викладена як українською так і
англійською мовою contile один захист 2
диплом проте коли я кажу що це так все
чудово коли я почала
досліджувати це питання яким же чином це
унормовувати в контексті нових вимог і
те що я бачу що ми повинні це просувати
ініціювати тому що це ну реально те що
нам потрібно
з'ясувало що дійсно ну в будь-якій бочці
меду ну без ложки дьогтю ну ніяк Звісно
що вона є але цей всі проблеми їх можна
подолати
ну перш за все і основна проблема те що
я бачу що в постанові написано що
видається
диплом доктора філософії
Якщо у нас відбувся захист в Україні то
країна іноземний партнер може видати
двох Джима видати другий диплом
якщо дітей відбувся в іноземному закладі
вищої освіти і це питання потрібно
ініціювати на рівні національної агенції
забезпечення якості вищої освіти
Міністерство освіти і науки України ми
повинні це реалізувати тому що це
потрібно Також ми повинні продумати як в
академічну довідку вписувати те що
навчання відбувалось за договором
хатітелів що там був залучений на повних
стовідсоткових підставах другий заклад
іноземний заклад вищої освіти цього
також на сьогоднішній день не
передбачено Також ми повинні максимально
адаптувати вимоги до дисертаційного
дослідження тому що це наразі
регулюється нашим освітньо-науковими
програмами нашої автономії ми це маємо
право робити і ми повинні створювати
такі Перемоги до самого до самого
опублікування і не опублікування а
написання дисертаційного дослідження щоб
воно було
співставним з вимогами тої країни це
також полегше життя аспіранту тому що
навчання подвійні аспірантурі ну це
також виклики не всі аспіранти на це
погоджуються і наукові
керівники я на передостання хотіла
сказати
англійську мову лазбатнути останнє але
не найменш важливе це те що нам потрібні
інформаційні ресурси щодо можливостей
грантової підтримки подвійного
керівництва аспірантами і я дуже
сподіваюсь користуючись нагодою що
національний фонд дослідження України
також буде передбачати серед своїх
грантових можливостей саме такий
вид підтримки Дякую вам за увагу
ще тут безпечний модель здобуття ступеня
навкового ступеня доктора філософії ви
теж звернули увагу на таких проблем і
важлива проблема що
добувають цього ступеня за кордоном все
ж таки повинен проходити в Україні
процедуру визнання цього диплому бо
автоматично ми не видаємо другий
дипломну про захист в країні партнерство
університету Це дуже важливо і на цією
проблемою треба працювати Тому що людина
вправа працю знання капіталу зуси себе
якщо в іншій державі визнали і науковий
ступінь присудили цей ступінь видалити
демократичним шляхом і врахувати ці
здобутки в Україні це питання потребує
що додаткового опрацювання щодо
можливості
внесення певних змін академічного
довідку Звісно що університети усі
сповна повинні скористатися засадами
правами автономії і ініціювати певні
зміни це питання також залежить від того
наскільки ініціативно будуть наші
університети наскільки їх є багато зараз
в Україні які працюють за підготовкою до
тарифілософії використовуючи програмну
Дякуємо пані професор І звісно ми зараз
переходимо ще до одної доповіді дуже
важливо є та доповідь у нас знаходиться
на завершенні нашого засідання
сьогоднішнього конференційного Чому Тому
що будь-яке управління завжди може бути
настільки ефективним що кінцеві будуть
усі задовольняти тому про науково
управління системою освіти ми запросили
сьогодні виступити пані професор Ірина
салух пані Ірина Доктор економічних наук
головний наголос співробітник відділу
економіки та управління загальної
середньої освіти і інституту педагогіки
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України пані Ірину будь ласка запрошуємо
вас Дякую
Шановні колеги щодо науки управління
у нас переважно вважається що є фахівці
серед нас є фахівці які є
вагомами такими суттєвими спеціалістами
будь-якій галузі і я думаю що одна з
таких сфер наукових це управлінська
діяльність ми знаємо все як управляти І
наразі забуваємо що наука управління це
дійсно наука яка має дуже суттєво
базу в своєму розвитку закон і
фактично
коли я збиралася говорити Про науку
управління то можливо
треба було б розглянути такі дві площини
перша - Це дійсно
реальний рівень управлінської діяльності
в сучасній українській системі освіти і
друга площина яка так само вони і
паралельно і такі що перетинаються і
накладаються одна на одну насправді
це друга площина Я хочу на неї звернути
увагу це фактично формування
[музика]
справжніх управлінців готових до
управлінської діяльності в 21 столітті в
процесі нашої педагогічної діяльності і
на рівні вищої освіти в першу чергу тому
що саме Там ми готуємо інженерів
агрономів педагогів які можуть бути
фахівцями в своїй певній галузі але вони
можуть або одразу і є такі приклади або
з плином часу стати управлінцями І от
надати таку кваліфікаційну
допомогу зробити щоб фахівець за певним
напрямом підготовки
спеціальним мав ще компетентності
управлінської діяльності Я впевнена що
це є
завданням нашої вищої освіти і навіть
середньої освіти ми в інституті
педагогіки
у відділі економіки управління середньою
освітою працюємо на сьогоднішній день
над проблемою державного приватного
партнерства
закладів середньої освіти і
однією з таких граней цієї теми це є
формування моделі компетентностей
керівника
навчального закладу в сфері середньої
освіти
про це Я скажу ще пізніше Наразі я трохи
готувалася для педагогічної спільноти
більш
в іншому плані але з того що я готувала
що мені хочеться сказати для нашої
поважної аудиторії Я б хотіла сказати
Наступне Що
недостатній рівень уваги до
управлінських компетентностей в процесі
підготовки наших студентів
фахівців різних спеціальностей це перший
момент і наступне коли вже у нас є
управлінці різних рівнів Ми знов-таки не
маємо
повної системи їх наукової підготовки Я
б хотіла зазначити нагадати Я впевнена
всім присутнім що
Пітер Друкер в свій час це його
дослідження
починається з середини ХХ століття Хоч
він не є
теоретиком
менеджменту як науки що зароджувалася
Але в той же час він є тою революційною
постаттю яка внесла суттєві зміни в
науку управління
так от Він говорив про управлінську
діяльність - це діяльність яка
відображає
рух нового часу дає сама собі розказує а
хотіла показати ще і
півторадрукіри це буде У нас свій я щось
не так нажала вибачте
Ага я повинна так зробити я так зробила
а воно для себе
що це діяльність яка відображає дух
нового часу
і теж він вказував на те що управлінська
діяльність найденамічніший елемент
будь-якого суспільства якщо ми сьогодні
будемо говорити І ми сьогодні говорили
дуже цікаві проблеми піднімалися в
різних сферах
практичної наукової діяльності
нашої науки то управління цими процесами
це найдинамічніший елемент наскільки ми
будемо змінювати підходи які у нас вже
існують ці зміни наскільки ми будемо
ефективними в нашому кінцевому
результаті і в досягненні тієї мети
заради якої здійснюється в цілому наша
діяльність тобто управління не потре
сьогодні трансцендентного доведення
обґрунтування і тим більше стає
безперечним рушієм тих змін що
впливають на всі результати діяльності
людства суспільства
навчального закладу фонду ради
вчених і молодих і не дуже тобто
підкорюються логіці інституціонального
прагматизму і це
надихає нас
дійсно ставитися Що ж я роблю я я
постараюсь в мене їх були не такі ну
такі я зрозуміла Я зрозумів
в системі освіти Я вважаю що можна
сьогодні сформулювати певні тоталізатори
рушії прогресивних змін які будуть
базуватися на саме і виходити з науки
управління Ну ви знаєте тут сьогодні між
іншим в науковій спільноті відбувається
дискусія щодо співвідношення термінів
менеджменту управління і ширше вужче і
так далі Коли студенти студентами
розмовляють то я кажу що управляти я
можу і своїм авто а от застосувати
менеджмент до авто я не можу тому
менеджмент - це управління соціального
соціально-економічній системі і про це
тому я використовую обидва терміни все ж
таки управління оскільки школи
управління
українські перед цим ті що панували на
більш широкій території
школи управління у нас дуже серйозні які
проглядаються від Академіка Глушкова і
інші наукові школи які Сьогодні діють в
Україні то я хочу сказати що
проблем ніколи питань системи освіти і
рухає
змінами які відбуваються в різних сферах
але необхідно підходити до нетривіальної
їх вирішення сьогодні на нашій
конференції демонструвалися
відходи від стереотипів мислення і
демонструвалися
непосивна вичікувальна позиція в роботі
освітніх установ а навпаки це те що
оптимально сприймаються
всі нові принципи менеджменту 21
століття і нові парадигми що я хочу ще
зазначити для того щоб
сформулювати нові ідеї які
хотілося б донести і ті які я вважаю
важливими на сьогоднішній день це те що
не в
сучасній економічній науці в українській
зокрема велика увага приділяється
останнім десятиліттям в останні
десятиліття проблемі креативного
управління а перед цим креатив до якого
призведе креативна освіта творчість
креативність у нас з'явився термін вже
креатосфера Якщо спостерігаєте за
розвитком економічної термінології то це
дуже цікавий підхід
кратосфера як Та що слідує за
економікою знань
тобто я хотіла показати
такі слайм
по-перше те що у нас на всесвітньому
економічному форумі 2019 року
спікери зазначали важливість
приділити увагу новим формам управління
освітнім і навчальним процесом
регулювали його тобто
називали шляхів яким чином можна цього
досягати але головними компетенціями
були названі 4K це креативність критичне
мислення комунікація І кооперація і не
виходячи з цього Я
останнім часом слідкую за тим наскільки
креативність стає
елементами нашої педагогічної діяльності
наскільки це важливо і хочу відзначити
що креативні
приймала участь в
конференціях України креативна починаючи
з першої цієї конференції дуже цікаві
цікаво представлені креативні
сфери нашої економіки і
на жаль до цієї креативної сфери не
відносять науку не відносять освіту
тобто креативною називають ті в яких от
сьогодні от зараз створюються новий
креативний продукт ви знаєте в мене був
парадокс коли на захисті диплому
психології
кваліфікаційної роботи Вибачте
студент
розповідав про
психолог студент психолог розповідав про
креативну сферу
музичну індустрію і оскільки я не
погоджуюсь з терміном що тільки
мистецтво
можна віднести 100% до креативної
індустрії Я вважаю що і інші сфери також
в тій частині в якій вони створюють нові
ідеї які реалізуються які не тільки
приносять
прибуток грошовій формі А які надають
імпульс і поштовх для розвитку е-е
майбутніх досягнень і Тобто ми не
повинні орієнтуватися на
концепцію збідніли ефективності
ефективності в якому досягаємо сьогодні
прибутку який ми досягаємо сьогодні ми
потрібні враховувати стратегічну
ефективність і тому студентом Я
намагалася я довершити думку вона мене
бентежить навіть до сьогоднішнього дня
Хоч пройшло вже пару років що він не
визнавав що може бути креативність в
інших сферах зокрема у виробництві що це
може бути креативним інженер А я
наголошую на тому що креативним повинен
бути управління науковець і таке інше що
я хотіла вам показати цікаву цікавий
слайд з себе показують Він у мене 20
в такому історичному аспекті як воно
відбувалося як необхідні формувати
креативного вчителя через відповідне
освітнє професійне середовище якщо
згадати те що ми мали в минулому
креативне виглядає сьогодні
досить примітивно хоч це ще не гірший
варіант для 70-го року хочу сказати а от
стисла до 2040 року у моєму забезпечення
економічного зростання стану
майже 50% креативні люди
промисловий комплекс Подивіться будь
ласка якщо ми сьогодні говоримо що це
дуже важливо що ми за рахунок цього
будемо вигравати
у війні будемо досягати нашої Перемоги в
першу чергу Ну я думаю що і за рахунок
креативних людей так само природні
багатства зберігають свою
вагу свій вагоми вклад в економічне
зростання але все ж таки переважати
будуть креативні люди
І ще хотіла навести те що дослідження
креативної освіти у нас на сьогодні не є
системними хоча ви знаєте я починала
тему дослідження креативної освіти і
креативного менеджменту
років з 10 назад коли їхала на
педагогічну конференцію в Польщу і думаю
Ну щось вже Взяти треба таке
незвичайне 10 років назад і тоді у нас
це було дійсно незвичайне така проблема
креативна освіта Я порадилася з
декількома колегами думку яких я
поважала вони мені сказали що це не
суттєве Але я маю таку не дуже хорошу
рису характеру не погоджуюсь хоч зроблю
так як я вирішила і я зробила Це з того
часу ця проблема Мене дуже турбує і я
хочу сказати що мала
позитивні літуги відгуки щодо своєї
доповіді на польській конференції але
все ж таки ще у нас не системне
дослідження проблеми креативності в
рамках інституту педагогіки Національної
академії екологічних наук в рамках
нашого відділу саме в моделі
керівника закладу середньої освіти я
буду розробляти вірніше я розробляю суму
модель саме креативності цього керівника
І ще що дуже я хотіла представити для
вас я хотіла
[музика]
я хотіла
навести дослідження британських вчених
які
задали для
в своєму дослідженні здали два питання
чи вважаєте ви що креативність та
інноваційність життєво необхідність для
росту компаній будь-якої 90 респондентів
однозначно відповідають так
а другим питанням Чи вмієте ви Тобто
управлінці надихати на інновації себе та
колег у повсякденній роботі і знов та
саме цифра але тільки з негативною
відповіддю не вміємо
формувати креативну команду і
американські дослідження оцінили ступінь
використання творчих можливостей
працівників у 20%. це не те що вони
мають цього 20% людей мають креативні
можливості це використання і ставиться
тільки 20 і така
такі слайд який характеризує що все
починається і я так вважаю креативною
особистості з того менеджера з того
управління з тої людини яка задає тон і
має цю
рису в своєму характері можливо її між
іншим вчених з
вже мабуть Ну якщо ви побачили перше
дослідження креативності було Ровно 100
років назад і перше визначення
креативності в 1922 році
також
Але існує дискусія чи креативність чи
схильність до творчості вроджена риса чи
вона піддається вихованню чи вона
набувається і переважна більшість і такі
класики як гілфорд гілфорд і
де воно вважають що це можна виховувати
яким чином Ну це вже Інше питання так от
починаємо з креативної особистості через
креативну групу А я скажу креативну
команду сьогодні було продемонстровано
дуже багато цікавих креативних команд Ми
сьогодні почули про досвід їх роботи
і тоді утворюються креативний процес
творчий процес який дає нам креативний
продукт зрозуміло що не повинно бути
креативне середовище Воно повинно бути
створено в суспільстві вони повинні
підтримуватися не різних рівнів і
різними засобами а креативний продукт
якщо я від
освітянської спільноти то я хочу сказати
що креативний продукт хай це не буде Ну
від мене від економіста це може звучати
нормально Це наш випускний креативний
продукт і
якщо ми
цієї мети досягнемо я буду вважати Я
вважаю що буде
успіх і у нас і короткостроковий - це
чого ми всі бажаємо але стратегічна
перспектива розвитку України буде
надзвичайно високою і всіх всі плани всі
ті що ми сьогодні не можемо здійснити ми
здійснимо Якщо у нас буде побудована
Креатор сфера Дякую за увагу
професор ви насправді використали засади
креативного менеджменту
дзеркаємо закінчили роботу нашої локації
цього інтуїтивно надзвичайно високий
результат можна сказати що це наш кре
навчальний продукт але насправді
креативним продуктом будуть наші
рекомендації які узагальні Максимова
головний спеціаліст відділу розвитку
науки Міністерства освіти України
запрошував цей Іванович підсумувати
роботу нашої локації сьогодні
дякую Михайлович Я хочу ще раз
подякувати всім учасникам і конкуренції
і нашої локації За ту роботу яку ви
зробили сьогодні під час участі в нашій
конференції За ту роботу яку вони
роблять щодня для того щоб наша країна
перемогла хочу подякувати нашим шановним
спікерам що відгукнулися що сьогодні
такі цікаві доповіді Ми почули на нашій
локації
і
керівництво університету що змогло нам
забезпечити таку гарну локацію причому
забезпечених умов тому що не Не кожен
може похвалитися дійсно
такими потужними обсягами і у котів і ми
обов'язково ще і
тому щиро вдячні вам за це
думаю що на цій ноті ми закінчуємо наше
засідання нашої локації і
після уже підбиття підсумків Я думаю що
це буде такий гарний для нас бекграунд
для наших подальших завершень Які якості
Шановні колеги я ще хочу нагадати що
запис нашої сьогоднішньої конференції
буде розміщений на веб-сторінки
Міністерства освіти і науки України а
також ми розмістимо із вашого дозволу
усі ваші презентаційні матеріали в
форматі не змінило PDF перетворення для
того щоб широкому загалу ми могли дати
можливість познайомитися із результатами
ваша з доповіді ваших досліджень з тим З
чим ви сьогодні до нас прийшли що
представили Дякуємо вам ще раз Мирного
дня наука заради миру